[Musique]
et avec nous ce soir pour en parler on
dirait avec danièle obono député la
france a soumises de paris soutien de
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir danièle obono
merci d'être avec nous valérie de bord
oratrice cellule riposte de valérie
pécresse candidate des républicains à la
présidentielle 2022 je parle bien de
valérie pécresse et et pas de vous
voiler les deux bords merci d'être avec
nous et sur ce plateau avec nous
philippe à bourrou iasi conseiller
régional écologiste en ile de france et
vous êtes-vous soutien de yannick jadot
lui aussi candidat à la présidentielle
merci à tous les trois d'être là
le taper bons rails nous dit
optimiste gabriela talent ce midi alors
c'est vrai que quand on voit ce
restaurateur on a quand même quelques
petits doutes notamment sur la stratégie
du du pass vaccinale qui fait grincer
des dents la plupart des candidats à la
présidentielle nous la branche seront à
même lit jean luc mélenchon à plusieurs
reprises c'est une ineptie danièle obono
pour la france insoumise se passe
vaccinale
c'est surtout qu'il est inefficace par
rapport aux objectifs que le
gouvernement prétend avoir par rapport à
la pandémie il ne s'agit pas d'empêcher
les contaminations puisque le 25 me le
permet pas ça réduit les formes graves
ce qui est utile et nécessaire mais en
vérité l'objectif ça a été de faire une
forme d' obligation vaccinale déguisés
et c'est ça le problème c'est que le
gouvernement a fait du vaccin la seule
réponse alors qu'elle ne peut être la
seule réponse et il le fait d'une
manière qui stigmatise une partie de la
population dont je rappelle pour les
personnes non vaccinées 40% n'est pas
vaccinée parce que l ils n'ont pas accès
aux soins donc c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement y compris
qu'une partie des personnes non
vaccinées ne le sont pas et quant à
celles et ceux qui ne le sont pas par
choix toutes les études et tout le
travail y compris de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui dit qu'il faut
convaincre et non contraindre montre que
c'est la pire manière de procéder que
d'avoir ce genre d'attitude en vérité
avec le pass vaccinale le gouvernement
emmanuel macron cliente en pagne fait un
coup politique il s'agit de désigner les
vaccinés qui seraient des bons citoyens
et qui s'identifierait à lui et à sa
politique et puis les non vaccinés qui
sera qui sont présentés comme des boucs
émissaires tout cela n'a rien à voir
avec la question de la pandémie parce
qu'il faudrait faire une politique plus
globale et et voilà pourquoi ces
problématiques et voilà pourquoi
effectivement nous sommes opposés au pas
de sanitaires nous sommes opposés au
pass vaccinale et nous mettrons en place
une autre politique d'aller vers une
politique avec des moyens comme par
exemple les touristes 14 novembre dans
les écoles on est 300 m danièle obono on
va on va en parler parce soit vaccinale
et record de contamination le cap est il
bon hein c'est la question qu'on vous
poser aussi ajouté des spectateurs
sortez les g une première réaction peut
être la réaction de david le pass 1
n'avait déjà rien de sanitaires la
preuve vous avez vu l'explosion du
nombre des contaminations il faut des
masques ffp2 partout nous mettre sous
masque se dévide c'est aussi votre avis
chez yannick jadot yannick jadot lui il
dit on est à des coupes décidées des
scientifiques et ils ne recommandent pas
le pass vaccinale le gouvernement fait
fausse route selon vous philippe
bourrier shi binbin complètement il va
droit dans le mur et il n'est pas prêt
de faire machine arrière effectivement
nous les écologistes nous sommes
attentifs à ce que les scientifiques
nous annonce parce que c'est eux c'est
leur job c'est leur spécialité et donc
on a une confiance totale envers les
scientifiques l'om est l'organe son
mondiale de la santé ainsi que le
conseil scientifique français ne
recommande pas une vaccination
obligatoire donc
certains moi je me base sur les rapports
de l'om est ce je pense que ça peut tous
nous mettre d'accord je ne suis pas
spécialiste et donc j'ai une totale
confiance en lui aujourd'hui
effectivement on assiste à une explosion
hier cinq cent mille cas donc le pass
sanitaires étaient inefficaces le pass
vaccinale va suivre le même chemin on va
arriver à un moment donné sur un plateau
dieu enfin une fois que le pic sera
passée puis une décrue est la
conjonction entre les deux que fait
emmanuel macron c'est de dire vous voyez
que grâce à la vaccination
nous avons un taux
minimum au moment où va arriver les
élections pour pouvoir en tirer les
fruits et la couverture vers lui sauf
que effectivement si vous ne mettez pas
dans les écoles les fameux purificateur
d'heure les détecteurs de co2 on voit
maintenant qu'ils ont encore du mal à
fournir des masques ffp2 aux profs toute
cette multiplication la vaccination bien
évidemment danièle obono l'a très bien
dit le aller vers convaincre plutôt que
contre 1 d'envoi d'ailleurs les
magnifiques reportages vous avez fait
sur la croix rouge qui va vers les gens
qui sont éloignés de la médecine et ils
passent du temps à convaincre a expliqué
à chaque fois qu'ils prennent 20 minutes
25 minutes avec un patient de bail
finissent par obtenir son consentement
et le vacciner al'inverse le
gouvernement veut y aller au bulldozer
fracturé la population nous monter les
uns contre les autres pour tout
simplement masquer son incompétence et
son efficacité alors on va se tourner
vers les rives de bord parce que chez
les républicains cette histoire de
passes vaccinale est loin de faire
consensus 1 valérie pécresse a même dû
un petit peu rétro pédaler passer des
classes seront puisqu'elle voulait je
suis privé les non-vaccinés de de
liberté on n'a pas dire merde et les non
vaccinés enfants n'étaient peut-être pas
loin vallée de bord il faut peut-être
préciser sa pensée chez les républicains
au risque de voeux ou confondre avec
emmanuel macron
je pense que les propos
caricaturaux
s'il voulait c'est beaucoup trop au
sérieux c'est beaucoup trop important
pour rentrer dans une polémique
politicienne oui j'ai vu que les
mexicains ça parce que je parle de
beaucoup de personnes qui disent voilà
ils sont en effet les républicains zinc
voilà c'était c'était l'objet de
détourner les propos de valérie pécresse
moi j'ai mon gars ici dit chez moi au
chru de nom si les médecins qui est
médecin dit il faut se faire vacciner
effectivement il y à davantage de cas
parce que tout est davantage mais il ya
beaucoup moins de gens qui sont en
réanimation il ya moins de décès moi ce
que je regarde c'est bien-être de notre
population c'est ça qui est important ce
qui est important c'est que si on ne met
pas autant de personnes qui étaient
vaccinés on se retrouverait avec des to
d'un si dense et de gravité bien plus
important alors c'est facile
effectivement
de vouloir jeter l'opprobre et jeté
l'opprobe c'est aussi jeter les moteurs
sur l'ensemble d'une profession une
profession qui est celle des médecins
qui disent tous qu'il faut effectivement
se faire vacciner de celle des soignants
des infirmiers qui ont levé l'ensemble
de leurs voix pour demander à l'ensemble
de la classe politique d'arrêter de
faire de la politique politicienne sur
ce sujet bien nous ça a été ce que nous
avons souhaité faire faire en sorte
effectivement d'avant tout regarder ce
qui pouvait être l'intérêt de l'ensemble
des français
le aller vers je suis désolé ça fait
deux ans qu'on fait du allée verte il ya
un certain nombre de personnes qui
n'accèdent pas c'est un fait ils sont
très très loin des 40% des gens qui ne
sont pas vaccinés aujourd'hui ou pour
chiffres je ne sais pas d'où ils sortent
certainement
des études scientifiques il a
certainement pas beaucoup de références
en tout cas ce pas les couper de la
croissance nous avons tonné me donnez
moi les références scientifiques de
cette étude donne et mettre à l'abri
donnez moi les références scientifiques
ont l'habitude de
donner moi c'est pas un sociologue chez
l'ex des métiers de la pluie donnez moi
et on va laisser peut-être qu'elle évite
de bord terminée je prendrai la parole à
l'acte ont levé réponse ils vont pleurer
d'aleri deux ventilateurs préparer
roland madame yade a beau bonhomme eu
aucune référence c'est facile de jeter
des chiffres c'est achille dans le voyez
c'est facile de dire des choses comme ça
il faut être responsable madame quand on
est un parti de gouvernement mais vous
n'êtes pas couvert blanc quand on est un
parti de gouvernement les républicains
sont repartis de règles de gouvernement
nous sommes aujourd'hui ont nécessité de
protéger l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
on a vu cette façon de faire
objectivement mais pas très digne
a essayé ce mot peut faire tous les
trois danièle obono je sais que vous
êtes habitué aux réponses l'ont donc je
voudrais vous fassiez s'il vous plaît
aussi ridicule alors que une mon
intervention n'avait rien contre les
républicains et madame a choisi de faire
une réponse politicienne absolument
indigne donc je lui demandais ce que
vous connaissez l'inserm madame est ce
que ça vous semble mais suffisamment de
l'étape l inserm ça s'appelle bien fermé
les piles
malheureusement la réponse
je pense que tout le monde est témoin du
fait que cette personne ne connaît pas
d'une ferme et remet en cause le travail
des scientifiques de l'inserm
je l'arrêté sous la bannière bonneau
responsable on va sortir de cette
polémique de 2,6 voilà vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et
cette personne est ignorante et dit
dépité sur votre plateau donc il n'y a
pas d'équivalence entre le fait de
remettre sur le fait voilà qui a
gagné logo on va vous laisser répondre
sur le fait voilà valérie de bord vous
dit on en appelle son opinion et quand
même aussi répandu dans la société
française dont il faut la respecter
quand même on allait bien à la
responsabilité des français
voilà il y en a moins en réanimation
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cela tout
simplement vous à la france inscrit mise
mais non devant je pense que si on veut
avoir un travail sérieux et respectueux
des faits on évite de mettre en cause
les instituts comme l'inserm des
sociologues j'ai vérifié girelli world
qui travaillent à l'inserm et qui a fait
cette étude très sérieuse nous nous
basons effectivement ce que dit le ms
qui dit il faut convaincre et compte et
non pas contraindre nous pensons que le
vaccin et je les dis en premier madame
si vous aviez écouté plutôt que de
chercher à pinailler et à remettre en
cause le sérieux de ce que nous faisons
depuis deux ans à l'assemblée nationale
nous disons depuis le début que le
vaccin est utile jean-luc fait les
onctions faisait partie des premiers
dirigeants occidentaux à avoir
signé avec notamment lula le président
du brésil une demande de la levée des
brevets pour permettre est-ce que ce
vaccin soit accessible à toute la
planète tous les pays qui le demandent
notamment l'afrique du sud et l'inde qui
sont en capacité d'en produire est ce
que vous vous soutenez la levée des
brevets madame est ce que vous pensez
que si bien sûr que c'est le sujet il
est bien sûr que je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi madame parce que quand ms dit
qu'il faut qu'il y ait au moins 60% de
l'ensemble de la planète qu'ils soient
vaccinés de la pop de la tortue lavancia
si on veut mettre un terme à la pandémie
c'est à dire à l'épidémie mondiale et
que on multiplie les doses les rappels
et c'est uniquement dans les pays
développés comme la france ou les états
unis eh bien on ne fera jamais face à la
pandémie et ça ce sont des faits vous
pouvez remettre en cause également l'
oms mais quand on est conscient
conséquent sur la grèce la bourse et des
profils une jauge au centre on nous a
totalement sur la même ligne en photo
avec jadot et jean luc mélenchon devrait
peut-être faire un accord on la choisit
d'anciennes ça c'est ça leur incombe
mais effectivement je rejoins
complètement et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'ai dit dans mon introduction la ligne
de danièle obono moi je pensais que
madame était une partisante de emmanuel
macron on voit que valérie pécresse à
mâcon sont sur la même longueur d'onde
riehl c'est vrai qu'entre droite on a un
petit peu du mal à faire la différence
mais
madame vos propos sont sont vraiment
violent madame la députée danielle obono
et moi-même dès le départ nous avons dit
que nos formations politiques nos
candidats sont pour la vaccination vous
que la seule chose au jeu blanc dans les
poubelles et des républiques ils sont un
peu méprisant en voulant nous nous
cornard ise en disant que nous sommes
des gens irresponsables
nous sommes pour la vaccination madame
sauf que nous n'avons pas la même
approche sur la méthode vous avez une
méthode frontale d'ailleurs excusez moi
mais il ya eu il n'y a pas eu de
discipline de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale concernant votre votre votre
groupe et donc ça je vous laisse laver
votre linge à l'intérieur et et tirer
les oreilles s'il faut tirer les
oreilles mais vous avez été un type en
discuter nous ce que nous disons c'est
nous sommes pour la vaccination est
depuis le début yannick jadot a été le
premier le premier avant même que la
vaccination soit mise en place
d'ailleurs on l'avait fait quelques
critiques nous dise effectivement qu'il
faut lever les brevets si vous ne
vacciner pas les pays du tiers monde si
vous en afrique c'est 8 % de personnes
qui sont vaccinées et si vous ne
vacciner pas vous allez vous retrouver
avec de nouveaux variants et on va se
retrouver dans la même étape tout le
temps encore et encore et encore le
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
fouillis de cafouillis on nous a dit
c'est six mois pour le rabais depuis
cinq mois puis quatre mois puis
maintenant trois mois nous sommes
complètement dépassés des français sont
son ans reste permanente est donc
maintenant il faut non simplement on est
rassuré il faut leur donner un message
cohérent et vous ne participez pas
malheureusement alors que je connais
votre sérieux madame vous ne participez
pas à ce débat et vous les kanari's et
madame reno qui a fait un travail
sérieux et remarquable et les
écologistes qui ont été à la pointe est
à l'avant garde sur la vaccination donc
arrêtons la politique politicienne et
parlant français et essaierons de les
convaincre pour qu'ils puissent vacciner
au lieu de les mépriser comme le fait le
gouvernement c'est que vous soutiens du
gouvernement un petit peu confus mélange
78 ans qui viennent nous écrire d'accord
avec vous le cap est illisible un audit
elle sortait d g on ne peut pas se
projeter tous les candidats à la
présidentielle ont intérêt à prendre
position contre c'est un grave recul de
nos libertés valérie d'abord ça c'est
vrai que c'est une critique qui revient
souvent ce recul des des libertés votre
réponse
si vous voulez nous les éléments sur
lesquels nous étions en désaccord
c'était le contrôle de l'identité
c'était un petit peu le reportage que
vous faisiez avec votre restaurateurs
nous considérons que un restaurateur
quel qu'il soit n'est pas forces de
l'ordre et n'a pas à faire ce contrôle
d'identité et on voit très bien que là
on est aux limites de ce système après
moi ce que je reproche aux personnes qui
effectivement ne lutte pas pour le pass
vaccinale c'est que en fait c'est aussi
une façon de pas donné le signal de la
possibilité de se guérir
d'impossibilité de ta être malade pardon
aujourd'hui on voit malheureusement trop
de gens qui sont aujourd'hui en
réanimation qui ne sont pas vaccinés
notre personnes sur dix qui sont
actuellement en réanimation sont des
gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés et c'est
quand même dommage de laisser à penser
que aujourd'hui bien ça n'est pas
possible c'est en fait que je trouve
extrêmement dommageable dont ces
positionnements et puis après renvoyé
sur des considérations qui certes sont
importantes par rapport aux brevets mais
c'est comme oubliée la responsabilité
qu'on a ou sa du territoire national
cette responsabilité elle est grande
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'il semble
extrêmement important
après faire de la politique politicienne
en disant vous avez les mêmes
comportements qu'untel ou untel quand
carl un comportement est responsable on
doit être responsable quand il est
irresponsable et bien il donne et doit
être dénoncée en tant que responsable et
c'est pas en hurlant le contraire que ça
va changer la réalité des choses donc je
vais te crever êtes vous pour la lever
madame mais monsieur monsieur monsieur
ça c'est du dilatoire c'est pas très
content et dilatoire c'est dilatoire moi
je vous dis que le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est le pacte
d'actionnaires sur le pad vaccinale est
irresponsable deux êtres bien au moment
de l'arrestation nous avons travaillé de
concert avec les européens la réponse
allait mondiales une pandémie mondiale
on n'est pas tout seul dans un village
de gaulois et le reste autour de nous
ils voient les russes travers il n'a pas
besoin de matériel mais kenneth van cu
des millions de doses
quand même des variations de gris mais
non absolument pas les promesses n'ont
pas été donnés je sais que vous êtes
aujourd'hui la porte-parole des manuels
macro madame mais ces promesses n'ont
pas été tenues et les pays une vidéo
demain à racheter les pays ne demande
pas la charité il demande la possibilité
de pouvoir produire eux mêmes le cas de
l'afrique du sud et c'est le cas de
langues et franchement moi je n'ai pas
envie de polémiquer avec cette dame je
n'ai juste lui donner la réplique ans de
l'enquète hlavackova kh3 d'accès nation
des enfants intentions de vaccination
contre le coc vie des usagers
l'application tout son petit caux livre
qui parle de ses 40% dont vous irez
vérifier je pense que les personnes non
non non écouter
jusqu'au bout l'étude porte sur y croit
et compris l'intention de vaccination en
général madame donc à trouver avec
malades et enfin je vous donnais les
petites ronan qui ont écouté jusqu'au
bout donc arrêtez avec ça nous avons été
conseil compte depuis deux ans à
l'assemblée nationale si vous êtes
sérieuse vous suivez les débats y
compris nous avons eu des accords avec
les députés à l'air sur la question des
droits et libertés et pas simplement sur
la question du contrôle c'est une
question qui remet en cause les libertés
fondamentales et ça pose question il ya
eu des débats quand nous avons essayé
d'en avoir il est dépité
l'arrêt après le mot de la fin pour
philippe bourrier à celle de ce qu'on
arrive à la fin de notre débat s'il vous
plaît mais valérie d'abord certains si
vous voulez c'est que aujourd'hui ce qui
est important c'est d'encourager le post
vaccinales c'est que moi je considère
que tous ceux qui ne le font pas
effectivement près d'une grande part de
responsabilité il joue avec la santé des
français c'est une réalité et que
aujourd'hui je trouve les propos madame
obono bien plus proches de ceux du
rassemblement rassemblement national en
l'espèce avec cette volonté en fait de
vouloir monter les gens les uns contre
les autres que ça c'est pas acceptable
et remettre remettre en cause les
scientifiques remettre en cause les
soigneurs remettre en cause les gérer
qui aujourd'hui risques aussi
vous leur vie que soigner les français
bien je trouve que ce n'est pas
responsable et les vivants c'est flou
c'est une fille teddy boy assez le mot
de la fin pour vous et rapidement s'il
vous plaît on arrive vraiment je suis
consterné comparer les membres de la
france insoumise aura au rassemblement
national sur ce point vraiment vous
faites déshonneur à votre parti écoutez
il y a un problème de santé majeur nous
avons des contrats compatriotes qui sont
en train de mourir au lieu de tous
travailler ensemble pour aller dans le
même sens vous essayer de tirer la
couverture vers vous pour une élection
présidentielle c'est juste lamentable
c'est vraiment dommage parce que j'avais
vraiment une autre image de vous et
notre image de votre présidente mais bon
effectivement entre choisir entre la
macro ni et valérie pécresse on va avoir
du mal à faire la différence merci à
tous les trois merci thibault et valérie
deux bords et danièle obono